heute soll es zum einen um eine
allgemeine Einführung in diesen etiktyp
gehen zum anderen soll eine der ersten
konsequenzialisten
Utilitaristen je nachdem wie man sieht
nämlich Jeremy Bentheim das genauer
beschrieben werden hinsichtlich seiner
philosophischen Ethik
ganz allgemein kann man sagen
Utilitarismus oder konsequentialismus
sind ein ethischer Grundtyp neben
anderen und Typen es gibt eben noch
andere und Tücken zum Beispiel die
deontologie da ist als Hauptvertreter
Immanuel Kant zu nennen oben rechts
mache ich einen Link dann rein zu einer
Folge über seine Ethik Vertreter des
konsequenzialismus hin zum Beispiel auch
John Stewart will der ist vor allem
bekannt aber auch der noch lebende
australische Philosoph Peter Singer
der Fokus des konsequentialismus liegt
wie der Name schon sagt auf den
Handlungsfolgen es gibt verschiedene
Spielarten des
konsequenzialismus oder auch das
Utilitarismus den Regel Utilitarismus
und den Präferenz unterlitarismus was
ist dabei genau auf sich hat werden wir
in eine der folgenden Sitzung noch
genauer sehen es gibt wie gesagt
Alternativen zum konsequentialismus bzw
Utilitarismus
tugenethik wäre eine Alternative Ethik
die den Fokus auf der handlungsqualität
hat oder der charakterqualität
vielleicht genauer die diese Handlung
zugrunde liegt
alles tot ist wäre hier als ein
Hauptvertreter zu nennen und die
Ontologie die ich schon kurz mit
Verweise auf Immanuel Kant geschrieben
habe also die
konsequentialistische Ethik ist nicht
die einzige auf dem Markt sie muss sich
verteidigen gegenüber anderen ansetzen
und sie hat auch in der Geschichte der
Philosophie viel Kritik erfahren
wichtige Begriffe im Kontext des
Utilitarismus sind der nutzen das liegt
bereits im Wort
utilis lateinisch nützlich also es geht
um den Nutzen einer Handlung der zum
Kriterium für die Moralität der Handlung
wird es geht um den das Glück der
Menschen vielleicht auch der nicht
menschlichen Tiere was vergrößert werden
soll genauso die Lust häufig wird hier
gesagt das ist Hedonismus Glück ist all
deinenismus und nutzen ist unter die
gitarismus Präferenzen die Interessen
von Lebewesen häufig wird auf das
Gemeinwohl rekoriert das sind mögliche
Kriterien anhand deren Mann nach
utilitaristisch konsequenzialistische
Auffassung die Moralität einer Handlung
bewerten kann oder genauer gesagt messen
kann
der konsequenzialismus der bewertet also
ganz allgemein die Handlung nach ihren
Folgen oft steht er bei den Nutzen einer
Handlungen Zentrum jetzt stellen sich
hier zwei Fragen einmal die Frage nach
der Extension des Nutzens oder der Frage
was fällt unter die nutzen Maximierung
wer als Subjekt ist es dessen Nutzen
vergrößert werden soll und die andere
Frage ist die nach der Bewertung und
Perspektive des Nutzens also
aus welcher Perspektive heraus ist der
Nutzen eine Handlung zu bewerten aus
meiner subjektiven Perspektive wenn ich
eine Handlung plane dann weiß ich ja
nicht genau welchen Nutzen daraus
hervorgeht oder aus der objektiven
Perspektive von außen gewissermaßen wenn
die Handlung schon erfolgt ist
also welchen Nutzen zählt bei unserer
Handlungen fällt unter Gemeinschaft
nutzensgemeinschaft Menschheit oder auch
nicht menschliche Tiere oder auch
Pflanzen die gesamte Natur also wer ist
das Subjekt
des Nutzens könnte man genauer fragen
die Perspektive und subjektiver
Perspektive können wir nur mögliche
Handlungsfolgen wollen planen
voraussehen wir wissen aber nie genau ob
die auch wirklich eintreten zum Beispiel
könnte es sein dass aufgrund von
Willensschwäche oder fehlerhafte
Erkenntnis oder Zufällen unsere Handlung
vereitelt wird oder in eine andere
Richtung geführt wird die eben gar
keinen Nutzen hat oder sogar Schaden
anrichtet also wir sind ein bestimmten
Hinsicht nicht völlig autonomen wenn es
um die
wirklichung von Handlung geht wir können
also genau genommen die moralisch
utilitaristische Bedeutung von
Handlungen ihres ermessen wenn Sie gut
sind und sich eine Weile in der Welt
ausgewirkt haben
daraus folgt jetzt ein Problem was man
auch ein Paradox nennen könnte wenn wir
mal die erste Prämisse die
konsequentialismus These die Moralität
unserer Handlung bemisst sich an ihren
Folgen die
heteronomethese könnte man nennt die
Handlungsfolgen liegen nicht gänzlich in
unserer Hand es könnte ja sein dass da
äußere Umstände die Handlungen in einem
anderen Licht erscheinen lassen die
Handlungen beiteln oder transformieren
und jetzt entsteht eine Art paradox das
heißt die Moralität unserer Handlung
bemisst sich wenn man den
konsequentialismus so versteht nicht nur
an unsere Entscheidung die den Nutzen
betrifft wir sind also für etwas
verantwortlich für das wir nicht
verantwortlich sind so könnte man den
konsequentialismus problematisieren weil
wir in einer Spannung uns befinden aus
interner Perspektiven die
projektiert die
vermutet die gute Gründe hat für die
Annahme dass seine Handlung gewisse
folgen die nützlich sind mit sich zieht
und einer externen Perspektive die ist
erst erlaubt nachdem die Handlung
geschehen ist sie wirklich objektiv zu
messen und den festzumachen da besteht
eine Spannung die man vielleicht sogar
auch als ein Paradox bezeichnen könnte
Immanuel Kant hat deswegen der lebte
Form diesen unter die Terroristen in
seiner Grundlegung zu hinter Sitten da
habe ich oben rechts wie gesagt dann
links drinne zu seiner
Schrift
er hat gegen den Konsequenz muss
argumentiert er sagt der gute Wille ist
nicht durch das was er bewirkt oder
ausrichtet nicht durch seine
Tauglichkeit zu erreichen irgendeines
Vorgesetzten Zweckes sondern allein
durch das wollen das heißt an sich gut
und für sich selbst betrachtet ohne
Vergleich weit höher zu schützen als
alles was durch ihn zu Stande kommt
die Nützlichkeit oder Fruchtlosigkeit
kann diesen Werte des Willens weder
etwas zu sitzen noch etwas abnehmen
darin sieht man ganz klar dass er eine
antikonsequentialistische oder genaue
antioutilitaristische Stoßrichtung
vertreten
jetzt diskutiert kann den Fall dass wir
zwar eine moralische Absicht gefasst
hatten gut motiviert waren dass daraus
jedoch keine nützlichen handlungsfragen
seine Auffassung nach sind deswegen die
Handlungsfolgen einer Absicht für ihre
moralische Bewertung nur äußerlich
wenngleich erkannt durch eine besondere
Ungunst des Schicksals oder durch
kirchliche Ausstattung einer
stiefmütterlichen Natur ist diesem
Willen diesen guten Willen gänzlich ein
Vermögen fehlte seine Absicht
durchzusetzen wenn bei seiner größten
Bestrebung dennoch nichts von ihm
ausgerichtet würde und nur der gute
Wille heilig nicht etwa als ein großer
unverbindlicher Wunsch als die aufbetung
aller Mittel zur Weizen unserer Gewalt
sind übrigens so würde er der gute Wille
wie ein Juwel doch für sich selbst
glänzen als etwas das sein sollen wird
in sich selbst hat und nicht äußerlich
die Nützlichkeit oder Fruchtlosigkeit
kann diesem Werte das moralischen will
etwas zusätzlich noch abnehmen sie würde
gleich dann nur die Einfassung sein um
ihn im gemeinen Verkehr besser handhaben
zu können oder die Aufmerksamkeit derer
die noch nicht genug kennen sind auf
sich zu ziehen nicht aber um ihn kennen
zu empfehlen und seinen Wert zu
bestimmen das ist natürlich eine
ziemlich ja provokative these die kann
hier
ja jetzt kann man hier natürlich
weiter problematisieren Immanuel Kant
hat nämlich auch gewisse Probleme die
seine Ethik betreffen so könnte man
jetzt die deontologie These nennen gut
ist nur ein guter Wille unabhängig von
seinen Handlungsfolgen
das ist das was kann im vorherigen Zitat
gesagt hatte jetzt gibt es die
heteronomiethese wir haben die Folgen
einer Handlung nicht in der Hand die
hatten wir auch schon beim
konsequentialismus gesehen und auch
daraus entspringt eine Art paradox also
ist selbst nach Kant eine Welt in der
nur gute Willen existieren aber keine
nützlichen Handlung daraus resultieren
besser als eine Welt in welcher wenige
gute Willen existieren jedoch zahlreiche
nützliche Handlungsfolgen entstehen also
selbst eine Welt in der es überhaupt zu
keinem guten Handlungen kommt wäre nach
kann eine
perfekte Welt vielleicht nicht aber
zumindest wenn ihr viele gute Willen
zugrunde liegen die aus welchen Gründen
auch immer eben nicht zur Handlungsfolge
kommen können weil durch irgendwelche
Umstände die Realisierung des Willens
alles Subjekte zur gleichen Zeit
verhindert wird
Gedankenexperiment aber man muss sich
das mal so konsequent vorstellen
das Problem der die Ontologie besteht
als in unserer starken Intuition dass
ein guter Wille einen kausalen
Unterschied in der Welt bewirken muss
das heißt dazu moralisch guten immer
auch eine Veränderung in der Welt
gehören muss darf nicht nur dasjenige
gut genannt werden was intrinsisch in
sich bleibt was nicht nach außen hin
gerichtet ist und das ist ein Problem
das gerade der konsequentialismus ernst
nimmt von Erich Kästner stand der Spruch
es gibt nichts Gutes außer man tut es
der gerade dieses Problem bezeichnet
also es geht darum dass man irgendwas
greifbar sichtbar in der Welt kausal
erleben spüren sehen fühlen kann nur
dann können wir wirklich von etwas
moralisch gute reden wenn es auch Folgen
hat und diese Einsicht die hat Jeremy
Bentheim sehr ernst genommen er hat eine
Schrift verfasst eine Einführung in die
Prinzipien der Moral und Gesetz geben
aus dem Jahr 1780 bzw 89
und nach seiner antwortologie werden wir
Menschen nur durch Leid und Freunde zum
Handeln motiviert er nimmt es ist nutzen
und darauf passiert seine gesamte
konsequentialistische Theorie
und sein System ist ein ethisches System
setzt sich zum Ziel das Gebäude der
Glückseligkeit durch Vernunft und rechts
errichten auch kant hat ein System
entwickelt eine Metaphysik der Sitten
und er versucht auch das Gebäude dieses
Systems zu entwickeln aber nur durch
Vernunft und nicht mit Blick auf die
Glückseligkeit die hat keine Bedeutung
und dann nutzen versteht Benton eine
Eigenschaft eines Gegenstandes bzw seine
Tendenz Zitat nutzen Vorteil Freude
gutes oder Glück hervorzubringen oder zu
verhindern dass
es nicht zu nutzen nicht zuvorteil nicht
zu Freude nicht so gute nicht zu Glück
kommen und das nennt er Schaden bleibt
oder Unglück
es handelt sich beim nutzen also
mathematisch gesprochen um einen Nutzen
Betrag die Verminderung von Leid zu
einem Normalzustand hin und die Erhöhung
des Glücks von malzustand hinauf sind
betragsmäßig gleich zu bewerben wenn sie
dieselbe Richtung haben nämlich ein
schlechteren Zustand ein relativ gesehen
schlechteren Zustand zu verbessern zu
einem Optimum hin zu überführen
entspricht Bentheim von einem Gesetz und
der Gebotes Nutzens welches für unsere
Handlung normative Geld hat jetzt könnte
man meinen dass Benten hier eigentlich
eine die ontologische Ethik
weil er ja
eine gewisse Nähe
darin hat wenn man sieht kann sagt wir
sollen so handeln das unser Wille
zu einem allgemeinen Gesetz werden
könnte so kann man sich manchmal die
deontologische vorstellen als ob es
darum die möglichst viel Nutzen für die
Welt zu zeigen das ist aber nicht
korrekt es geht Immanuel kann nicht
darum dass der Wille eine große Nutzen
hat sondern es geht ihm nur darum dass
der Wille vernünftig ist und
verallgemeinerbar ist ohne Widerspruch
unabhängig von irgendwelchen
Konsequenzen wir haben gesehen warum
das heißt sie kann geht es nur um die
Form der Maximen nicht aber um deren
Inhalt und auch nicht um die
Konsequenzen der Handlung den diese
Maxim zugrunde liegen
ganz kategorische Imperativ fördert
nichts Konkretes wir die Vergrößerung
nutzen sondern nur dass unsere Maxim
sich nicht wieder sprechen
ja jetzt unterscheidet Benton vier
Quellen oder auch wie es in Sanktionen
die Grund und Ursache von Freund und
Leid sind physisches wie z.B Schmerzen
Krankheiten
natürlich die Vermeidung von Schmerzen
Krankheiten also körperliche Freude
politisches
im negativen Sinne ist es zum Beispiel
staatliche Bevormundung moralisches man
könnte sich hier Beleidigung vorstellen
und religiöses und er hat auch viel
Kriterien entwickelt um die Quantität
muss man genauer genommen sagen im Sinne
von Intensität der Freude und Leid zu
messen Intensität Dauer Gewissheit oder
Ungewissheit Nähe und Ferne und Freude
oder leid es sind alles objektiv
feststellbare Qualitäten die eine Freude
oder ein Leid haben kann mit dem wir
sozusagen rechnen können es
unterscheidet er hier 14 Arten von
Freude
Sinnesfreuden und Freunde das Reichtums
der Kunstfertigkeit und so weiter und so
fort
ein auf ihn folgender denke John Stuart
Müller hat kritisiert dass Benton hier
gar keine qualitative Hierarchie
vorgenommen hat alle Freuden werden hier
gleich behandelt dabei könnte man sagen
dass vielleicht die eine Freude wie zum
Beispiel die Freude der Freundschaft
vielleicht höher zu werden ist als die
Freude der macht weil sie eine
moralischere Qualität hat nicht nur
irgendwie auf Äußerlichkeit gerichtet
ist genauso nennt Menschen einige Arten
von Leid das Leid der Entbehrung die
sinnesleiten letztendlich ziemlich
analog zu den Freuden auch hier kann man
sich fragen ob vielleicht nicht doch das
eine Leid ja moralisch gesehen
problematische ist als das andere das
war's für die heutige Sitzung in der
nächsten Folge geht es dann darum wie
sonst wird mehr die Theorie von Benten
kritisiert und in seiner Theorie des
Utilitarismus eine
alternative Konzeption von Ethik
entwickelt